shark tank's kevin o'leary was recently
asked about bitcoin in the crypto market
he had a very interesting thing to say
he explicitly mentioned that we need
some sort of panic event to actually get
to the crypto bottom now of course
trying to time bottoms is really
difficult and no one should sit there
and try to make investments based on
what they think the absolute bottom is
but kevin's got a great point here he
went on to say that he thinks someone
needs to go to zero and that's when
we'll get that bottom event
well we've seen a number of different
firms actually go ahead and be insolvent
or shut down or look for restructuring
and as we continue to see more and more
of these suffer at the hands of
liquidations and all the leverage that
was in the system i tend to think that
we may have multiple firms that go to
zero before it's all said and done but
that idea of a panic event that final
capitulation that wash out of the people
who are holding on to the last hope that
definitely has to happen before we get
to the bottom and as kevin o'leary
pointed out all markets are the same
they're made up of humans with the same
human psychology the end of the day
somebody has to be hurt in order for a
market to bottom and then all of those
resources they get reallocated and then
we have the tough task of rebuilding but
something tells me that we're closer to
the bottom than we obviously were before
the question is who will survive and who
will make it to the other side those
that do they earn the right to thrive
during the next bull market hey you did
you like this video great we make five
of them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time